hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the man from the window
2. if you remember man from the window
one of the most memorable things about
the man from the window wasn't
the man in the window what in the what
what what
you know what I'm talking about
[Music]
you know what I'm talking about oh no
you know what I'm talking about you sick
foreign
from the window too so I imagine there's
going to be a man
in another window
in normal mode you were given a notepad
to help keep track of things
well I don't even know how to play so
I'm assuming it would be a bad idea to
do tough
press X to skip why would I do that
hello
I knew they would bring her back I just
had a funny feeling hello Junior
oh Junior's all grown up hey Ma is
everything all right yeah I'm fine I had
a few minutes left to spare before my
break's over so I figured I'd give you
two a call just to check in you know two
oh thank you we're both fine over here
too who's two to the man from the window
just blossom into a romance I found a
few extra dollars in my purse so we
ordered some takeout shouldn't take too
much longer to get here I'd reckon
awesome awesome y'all too enjoy I better
get off this phone and get back to work
then
we got a bunch of stuff to move out here
tonight and it's my turn to drive the
forklift yeah oh tell a little missy I
said hello would you will do hun later
thanks mom we'll talk later
all right
Audrey
oh hi yeah grandma
your papa says hello he's still at work
yep called during his break now did you
finish that homework of yours yet yeah I
did Grandma dude that's what I like to
hear
oh oh I was proud of the food I'll get
it
I could have sworn I heard someone out
here knock didn't you Audrey uh-huh
oh
my stars here we go
Audrey he's back the man uh-huh he sure
is knowing ain't he isn't he hun I don't
want you speaking messed up English like
Grandma does but yes he is
why'd you take the you didn't have to
take the book I don't know if that's
part of it we're gonna go through the
book together this time okay and I want
you to pay close attention your papa and
I ain't always gonna be here so you need
to know how to do this for yourself
I understand Grandma I think
oh boy time will pass the seasons may
change we know that nothing can ever
stay the same but the man continues to
play his Twisted game
request is all he's ever wanted in his
unending search these dark streets he
has haunted one night fall once night
falls you'll know he's on the prowl keep
far away else you'll meet a fate that is
assuredly most foul a faint tap
a faint tapping at one's window has
always been his has been his Herald so
spend these next five minutes wisely or
you may find yourself suddenly imperiled
it's a little rough man from the window
you can do better than this now proceed
with caution and proceed with haste for
the man has learned that there's no time
to waste
well what the rest of the pages have
been torn out well that's not fair
Aubry we're gonna die
now very closely we're both dead well
one of us is and let me tell you I
didn't survive this long by not making
some Cutthroat decisions
not getting it what's the first thing
we're supposed to do when this happens
uh this is important Audrey I know you
know this hun the pages we got to put
the pages back in the book before we
hide because the man got angry and tore
them out that's right
okie dokie then so go get it Aubry oh
it's a page
well a Slenderman uh seven pages don't
know how he got splushing him all over
already it's our kitchen closet the all
breeds are kitchen closet do you
understand
oh there's one
still some pages left to put back here
man when that food gets delivered that
man better take a break because I'm
hungry
all right here's another schwabam
I'm sure there's more
okay
[Music]
I don't know what I was expecting
there's another
ah this guy congratulations to miss
Diane rabbit on your retirement for 38
years of faithful service
what a delay thank you so much that
makes me feel so appreciated
hey what's up there
oh this is a great game it's got
Reflections and everything it's nice
having an actual bathtub yeah
that is nice I suppose
oh anything in here
it's the hall closet the roof leaks when
it rains so we took everything out of
there okay Audrey did you know that
did you know that do you know you know
that Audrey do I have anything anywhere
else
I feel like this isn't all the bit oh
wow
I can't undo that that's forever now you
understand that
all right what do we got there's still
some pages left to put back in here oh
where oh
excuse me Audrey excuse me
uh well
all right interesting then
Grandma I don't like when this guy shows
up I know how neither do I but still we
better count our blessings some folks
around town have things worse than we do
I don't know how
that's an interesting sentiment
oh Paige oh do I get to go out of the
apartment to go to get the pages
I gotta go downstairs to get the pages
off
this is ridiculous
those were goddamn ridiculous
I didn't retire after 38 years of
breaking my back at a bakery admittedly
it might have not have been the baking
that uh affected my back thusly
but
still not going to hear any sass or
ought to be one more page around here
somewhere well where
I don't see it
I don't see nothing
there ain't nothing out here
I ain't got nothing
this is stuck under my brassiere I would
never know if it was there hey uh Audrey
oh it's the old bathtub
so he uses to wash clothes someday we'll
get a washing machine that'll be the day
all right well do you know where the
last thing is trash can
paper towel
oh nope
oh okay
well I think uh Audrey I think we might
be dead
oh there it is oh time's been moving
well that's probably not good okay the
man is happiest when his hunt for a
friend is a foot his next move is to
search the place where boxes are put
smiling ear to ear the man always shows
his teeth the next place he'll check is
the sink with a cabinet underneath
completely focused the man's demeanor is
scathing he will now search the place
reserved for bathing the man remains
Vigilant his hopes tonight will not be
squashed his next course of action is to
look in the place where clothes are
washed not many things could stop the
man neither Force nor containment now he
will look under the box watched for
entertainment not finding a friend is an
outcome the man won't accept he will
next look where the clunk clean clothes
are kept I don't even know where that is
um wait what is this kitchen closet
bathtub all closet old washed up oh wait
oh
that's helpful for me it's the fridge
Audrey could hide in here for a bit if
she needs to and then freeze to death
yeah right I guess technically I should
probably click these it's the kitchen
sink cabin and Audrey can either no
problem now where where would I hide
where am I gonna hide
let's see it's a TV stand if need be
Audrey can hide in here
probably not I think I heard that in the
the rumor mill
um it's Audrey's bed she's hidden under
there before
that's kind of sad
um oh that's where the okay it's our
clothes hamper Audrey can fit in here no
problem
all right well that's good to know
um
I think that's probably all the spaces
oh it's a bathroom sink Audrey can hide
under there for sure
for sure
absolutely and then I already clicked
this one okay whole closet I think
that's all the hiding spaces
yeah that's all the hiding spaces so if
he is I'm out of time
um
where the boxes are put that is the
kitchen closet okay kitchen closet uh
cab sink cabinet underneath that's the
kitchen sink so definitely not the
kitchen closet definitely not the
kitchen sink got it sorry Audrey uh
we're out of time
um
reserved for bathing that's the bathtub
uh the clothes are washed so that's the
bathtub and the old wash tub and then uh
the TV box and the laundry hamper okay
so TV stand and the hamper right okay oh
[__] uh get in the fridge Audrey in the
fridge in the fridge Audrey get in the
fridge get in the fridge
follow me follow me take my hand get in
the fridge get in the fridge Audrey
don't you get in the fridge
all right now what
oh where can I oh
I have to
oh no it was exactly 8 P.M when the man
approached the entrance Door ah
I'm not a goofed although he had only
five minutes to accomplish his goals
that night this time the man was ready
damn he's quick okay well this is
awkward hi the man had finally found his
new friend
ah hey wait wait wait wait wait
oh hey Ma where's the front door wide
open hello Audrey
is Audrey gonna I thought Audrey was
gonna be a frozen corpse in the fridge
Audrey what happened and where's your
grandma at Audrey talk to me
was it
[Music]
well I I sure took my sweet God damn
time didn't I
yep all right let's try that again can I
skip the intro this time next to skip
got it all right otter shut up we gotta
move we gotta move
[Music]
right you know it's so good oh here we
gotta go I don't know where I'm gonna be
able to fit in all this it doesn't make
a lot of sense
let me at least get them on my list my
enormous chest could get out of the way
for just one second I can move faster
let's go I wonder if I could barricade
like the door or something isn't that
something that was in like the last game
no
there's no barricading here
there's no barricading pole oh well
that's convenient all right
let's close this uh I know I'm letting
all the cold air out of the fridge but
don't matter it's Audrey's bed
definitely hide there
the old wash tub
now it's only used for players
see laundry hamper I don't even know if
I could fit in there
okay I think that's all the places to
hide anyway uh
okay uh walk close washed and then
laundry hamper got it okay
close wash all washed up and the hamper
is off limits uh
there's a place where food is stored so
fridge and then under the bed so that's
no good
uh fridge uh the bed got it
okay so that's on off limits uh
uh TV and then bathroom sink okay so TV
stand and then bathroom sink
so he didn't say bathtub
so that's easy so you child you go under
the kitchen sink I'll go in the kitchen
closet yeah
follow me take my hand get in there
okay get in there get in there dummy
stay quiet you I think I should just at
least try to close the doors
there we go okay and in the closet I go
maybe I shouldn't have left a list out
where I am that's probably not good
where am I hiding here
I get out of here too I suppose hide
here
perfect
easy
it was exactly eight did you be dead
[Music]
man was ready hello
hmm suspicious the man looked inside the
old wash tub
but he found nothing not even a rub
the man looked inside the clothes hamper
but he found nothing his mood
was dampered
the man looked inside the fridge
just Frozen corpse but not a friend
the man looked under the bed
without nothing
man looked inside the TV stand
but found nothing
fascinating
oh God I see crotch God ah my eyes my
eyes
looked under the sink
I found nothing
time was ate it wait a minute
and though he still had plenty of time
left the man had run out of places to
search so as quickly as he arrived he
left
but that didn't take up all the time
what is that about
yeah and stay gone this time don't think
you could just run in here mess with
Grandma and me because I'll
oh
yay
I like food
Adriana you don't need to be scared it's
just to take out we ordered Audrey what
have we got to do with that child being
silly and scared of weird naked tall men
merging into our home looking for
friends okay so that was I got it
all right so now I I gotta go tough mode
I actually gotta think about what I'm
doing okay we're gonna go tough mode
here all right I'm gonna skip this
because I'm assuming it's largely the
same but the benefit being I don't even
need to look at all the locations I just
gotta remember it okay easy easy okay
really there's no like nailing stuff up
there's no boarding things up what is
that oh
we're too stupid to write we couldn't
possibly think about how to do that
just give to babadook
another one there
I can't wait to get the ultra secret
Deluxe ending
Scooby-Doo
foreign
that's all of them I believe
swalla
what one more page what do you mean one
more page oh there it is
I I know it's the fridge
schwaba okay
he will check the place under the mirror
okay bathroom sink and then bathtub okay
uh unclean closer laundry hamper a bed
uh empty room is where he will look next
okay that's hall closet TV stand sink
cabinet food is stored so the fridge
okay this is eight places now so sink
and bathtub are off limits so that whole
room and that hallway closets the hamper
is off limits the bed is off limits TV
is off limits the kitchen sink cabinet
and the refrigerator are off limits okay
that just leaves the kitchen closet come
with me and the old wash tub we gotta go
let's move get in the tub you'll be fine
he's real dumb get in that wash tub
get in the tub
maybe I should be in the tub I see your
eyes peeking there
all right but I'm going in the closet
again
I definitely shan't to be found
and then close the front door and then
get in that closet and I think I'm good
hide
mm-hmm
[Music]
foreign
whoa what and since the blinds had been
left open he knew exactly where to oh
wait no wait but I was smart
ah well this is awkward
huh
right the blood I forgot about the blood
the blinds yeah the the the the the
blinds the blinds
right lines sure blinds blinds
I thought there was a reason that that
needed to be done
there's probably other secret rules that
I'm going to learn very quickly
get that in the freaking plan already
is he in the window if would I like
catch him looking in the window
I mean it's kind of an indication yo the
man from the window I get that I should
have closed the window but it's like is
he is he really
okay
so uh wash tub is out TV's out sink
bathroom sink is out
kitchen closets out kitchen sink is out
empty room and the hallway is out
bed is out fridge is no good okay so
that's Wash Tub TV Wash Tub TV uh
bathroom sink kitchen closet
kitchen sink empty room sleep and food
is stored so I think that's the bathtub
the bathtub and the laundry hamper okay
got it all right let me close these up
here
you come with me you're getting in the
hamper you're gonna you're gonna go in a
hamper you're gonna fit right in
you get in that hamper get in the hamper
don't you come out
no that was a test don't say anything at
all
close all these up and then no wait the
bathtub right is the front door closed
we all closed this is not closed close
this
uh I'm good I'm gonna take a bath
I'm hiding
you'll never find me
idiot
I am
hmm
nothing there
stupid idiot
what a dumbass
foreign
I don't think there's many other places
to look up the time was now 803 and
though we still had plenty of time left
the man had run out of places to search
so as quickly as he arrived he left
which I feel is very different from the
last time I feel like
I feel like he you needed to occupy his
time
well that was simple
never mind
never wait you didn't run away oh
who the hell are you the man from the
window wait lyxian digitally removed
that mustache goatee eyebrows hair
clothes and the basket that he's holding
replace it with a window take the hat
off of him too oh my God
it's the man from the window got no idea
for Miss Diane that's me finally I'm
starving after all that hiding
what's going on here
wait what's going on here
it's a super secret Deluxe ending
oh hey Ma you sure are up late tonight
aren't you uh-huh I was waiting to tell
you something yeah what's up the man
showed up again today oh no is Audrey
okay don't worry hon she's fine but I
wanted to tell you that she handled
herself really well didn't I at all
considering it won't be long before
she's ready to deal with the man all by
herself I reckon that's that's my girl
that's weird she's one tough cookie all
right she takes after her grandma you
know well ain't that the truth
now that I've told you that I better you
dumb ass good now Junior good ammo see
you in the morning
universally it's only like two beds that
was it
there's no Ultra Super Deluxe tough mode
that's it
what happened to all the nailing of the
things of the one you know there's only
one reason why I play this game again
it's not that it's bad I'm not trying to
imply that it's bad it's a perfectly
fine game it's got interesting mechanics
but I think that's one reason and one
reason only why we why we're all here
and why we're here to the end it's the
absolute
just perplexity of it all when it comes
down to the main character model
I think we can all agree on that but hey
we got two stars that's great I know I
wish it was a secret third star but
apparently there's not so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know your thought down in the comments
below if you were here for a different
reason than the one we all agree and
don't need to speak about that we're
here uh let me know in the comments
below and then we'll talk about that
we'll really discuss that because that
needs to be discussed okay all right you
need to think about what you're doing
with your life
understand
now go close your windows because the
man from the window is going to check
your bathroom sink your bathtub your
laundry machine just the washer and then
the dryer and then it's going to check
your fridge under your bed over your bed
under the covers on the ceiling in the
basement in the box in the basement and
then in your car and in the trunk of
your car every part of your car even the
engine block is going to look there uh
so just be careful find one place really
quick you have five four
three two one
[Music]